[Music]
all right let's go to nicole in
indianapolis what's up nicole
oh nothing much how are you dude we are
dancing on the ceiling lionel richie
style what's up
okay well i'm super nervous so hopefully
i don't screw up um have you ever
listened to this show
frequently yeah i'm not that good either
we're good same team what's up what's up
okay
i'm gonna throw a lot at you so
hopefully
it's all it all makes sense
um you know i've been married i've been
married for almost 10 years my husband
is a new uh pastor
um like within the last
sorry two years um he is visually
impaired
um
[Music]
like percentage-wise probably about 90
percent like he's got some light
perception okay um
but he uses his cane to get around and
um guides off of me and
people in unfamiliar places okay so so
yeah he's not getting around restaurants
he's not driving anything like that
yeah correct okay all right cool um
i'm a mom to a one and a half year old
i'm a stay-at-home mom
i run a women's bible study i babysit
another toddler two times a week i
actually just started door dashing a
couple times a week to help
make bring some extra money home i cook
i clean i do laundry
and by the end of the day i'm just
completely exhausted and burnt out and
um too tired for sex and other intimacy
um and some days like i can't even stand
to be touched like my husband will come
home and give me a hug and i'm just like
i literally will cringe and pull away
and it's like just
like don't touch me i've been touched
all day
what do i do
[Laughter]
don't touch
me i made that mistake before yeah this
is hard um
could i ask you hard questions
yes
like we're on the dial
from 10 being
kind of brutal hard questions and one
being like
what's the weather like
um be
be brutally honest okay
hat is your husband's eyesight been
degenerative or has it been that way
since you you all been together
um so we
have
been together since
2009
and when
we met it was pretty much right at the
height of his um vision loss he's always
been visually impaired since he was
really little
but that steep the steepest rate of
decline was
that junior year of high school through
freshman sophomore year of his college
um
so when i i've always known him as a
blind person
and
um
yeah so he was pretty much where he is
now back when we met
so
some of the
some of the just the innate challenge of
having a one and a half year old your
body's not yours still
yeah
and you're a human jungle gym
and you are a
human
um grocery store and you're a human and
somebody has to watch you go i remember
the first time my wife was gone and my
son was really young and i had to go to
the bathroom and i didn't know i was
like oh
i i guess you're coming in like i didn't
know i mean i never that thought had
never occurred to me
and
so somebody stares at you while you go
to the bathroom or talks to you worse i
don't talk to anybody in the back right
it never stops
and so some of this
a lot of this is you have a one and a
half year old
and i would tell you to give yourself a
lot of grace
okay i would tell you to
have conversations about that with your
husband speak it out loud underneath
that this is a harder question and just
be honest with being yourself
and
i'm not leading you i'm just asking a
question a lot of folks that i know who
have romantic relationships or kids with
special needs
both love
the the things that make their partner
unique or their kids unique
and it's really frustrating
and it's super annoying and i just god
can you just go get your own diet coke
but nope you can't you know what i mean
how much of that plays into now that you
have a one and a half year old now
there's a new job now you're trying to
pay off debt
it's like god almighty i don't know
where the toilet paper is can you just
but i gotta go get that too because in
many ways it's like having a second
young person in the house right
yeah i think
um i hadn't
put a whole lot of thought into it um
but
yeah like before we had we were together
for
i'm not great at math but like eight
plus years before we had a baby
um so it's like before the baby it's
like oh yeah that's fine you know drive
you where you need to go go get that
thing
help you read the menu it's like it's
not a thing but now it's like when we go
places it's like i've got
this
little child who can't do anything for
himself
um
and but i still have to help my husband
too so
i hadn't i hadn't put a whole lot of
thought into that
and you avoided the question like a like
a ninja sorry you don't even have to you
don't have to answer it but but hang on
to it okay okay
i want to free you're allowed to be
frustrated and you're allowed to be
really annoyed
and you're allowed to be pissed off that
your husband
is that he is sight impaired it's okay
it's when you take it out on him and
that's where i would challenge your
actions and stuff like that but it's
okay and a lot of people beat themselves
up for those those lightning bolt
thoughts
and like god dude
oh she could just drive himself to the
freaking grocery store
um and i got to figure out how to do
this with my this schedule and that
schedule now i got a one and a half girl
he's got to eat and if after he eats if
i don't get him down then it turns into
a whole thing
and then husband's used to the old days
where you were basically his uber
service right
so
you've heard me talk about this a lot
this happens with all people who have
their first kid
and
that they have this first kid and not
everybody in the house is on the same
page with how much has changed
and so in your home 100 of everything
has changed all of it every second of
your life has changed and so instead of
getting frustrated to him getting
frustrated because he has lived a
certain way for eight years he's come to
depend on you and you on him and you'll
have a great rhythm and that rhythm is
now different forever it's gone forever
and now you have this new baby and so
it's gonna have conversations about we
really want to get out of debt but this
isn't the six months to do this
we need to make some extra income
um we're going to figure out another way
because i can't do dinner and this and
this or
we're going to have to get some help
around here i'm going to have to have a
college student come over after hours
and watch the kid while i do this so
that i can right so we're gonna have to
be very intentional about here's my
capacity
because you can't do what you were and
just dump a one and a half year old on
top of all of it and deal with a new job
that's a ministerial job that takes
a whole family to do often anyway
you know what i mean
yeah
and then
now we're to the
sex part
to the intimacy part what's going on
there
um oh
that's so awkward i've never like
compared to my husband i've never had as
high of a sex drive as him so
sometimes it's a little more of a chore
for me it's like well you know gotta get
him what he
gotta get him what he needs um
i try to be intentional about it but
it's different when it's when you have a
baby and it's like i've been on the go
all day
um
so
we've had some conversations about it
we've had you know like these are you
know my needs like
i
we we obviously can't write letters to
each other but we did an email
um and i said these are some of my needs
you know i
you know abc and then he actually did
the same thing he sent me an email with
some of his needs and
um
it was just age
i think not really i know i know i'm
just messing with you
um here's what i want you to do i want
you all to get the book together
and read it's called come as you are
by emily nagotsky
um and i want you able to read that book
together and there's going to be parts
of that book that are like whoa
um and it is it is it is not
it's written for women
but one of the things that's um it's
been eye-opening for every guy i know
that's read it in a in a positive way
and in particular
she does a great job peeling apart the
myth that sex is a drive that some
people just have more than the other
what she proves
physiologically is that sex's act sex
drive if you will is actually a series
of
gas pedals and breaks
and what every couple's that women's sex
drive is not men sex drive light
that it's just different entirely and if
you will focus more on the brakes and
the gas pedals instead of this myth
about well i just don't like it as much
or
women just feel this way or guys just
everybody's different and if you think
about the brakes and the gas pedals and
she walks it through in a remarkable way
um i finished that book and i recommend
it to everybody i
i mean oh my counselor for everybody i
thought needs to read this it's just a
great book on sex and intimacy for women
but as a guy i read it and i was like oh
my gosh i didn't know half this you know
what i mean so
it's a great book to open conversations
there are parts of that book that'll be
awkward for you to sit with your husband
and read no question about that and by
the way you've already made a human
we're past awkward at this point right
we're married
um so let's have some grown-up
conversations but i think that would be
a great
it's it's a step beneath the the needs
conversation what do you need and what
do i need this is more
how do i create a world for you
where
you are free to run wild with desire
with intimacy with rest
with all these really with connection
these really important things that we
don't give ourselves permission because
we just add another job and another
payment to a thing and another car and
we just keep going and going and going
and this gives this book is great
languages come as you are by emily emily
nagotsky um
this is probably gonna mean
that you'll have to get some help around
your house for a season
and that
can make you feel like you're not enough
that can make you both feel like we
can't afford this
i'm gonna tell you that a little bit of
help in your life
will
pay
the investment in a little bit of help
whether that's someone to clean your
house once a month or once every two
weeks
and it's just a high school kid can you
come take out the trash and vacuum you
don't have to do the baseboards or
anything crazy
um can you watch
little timmy while i go and do what like
what getting some help
will be huge hey honey instead of me
picking you up you're going to start
getting an uber ride
and i know that sounds like not sexy and
romantic but this is where we are right
now you got a full-time job and i am
working and i'm at home and i got a baby
so let's get creative and let's take off
all of the
well we can't and we shouldn't and that
just doesn't make sense and that doesn't
look right we're past all that stuff now
now we're trying to do is continue to
love each other in this brand new season
it's just going to take us to think
differently not just do the same things
we've always been harder and faster got
what i'm saying
how does that sound
we have a lot of it it sounds like at
the surface level it's like oh yeah
that's doable i know
this person and this person this person
will all love to watch
the baby and it's like that's so hard
for me personally that's a whole other
call that that's it's like
accepting defeat but like i know it's
not but that's how it feels like oh i
can't do all these things no answer
answer is no you cannot yeah yeah
guess what nicole
you need help
and support
and i haven't even yeah it's a whole
call we haven't even gotten into hey you
got to make sure you're exercising too
and you got to make sure you have time
for you to eat right and to
write and to read and to think
and to not just try to duct tape each
day together so you get the next one and
then super glue that one so you get to
the next one and then wrap an extension
quarter on that once you get to the next
one your life is worth more than this
so much more
so even before you have the help
conversation let's have a you've had the
needs conversation let's take let's go
let's make that thing bigger
new season we're building something
totally new totally different what do we
want this to look like well honey i
really liked it when you picked me up
every day well that's not happening
cause we made a kid so i like it when
you're home at five so we're gonna set
this side this much budget money for
uber rides and two hours a day three
days a week i'm going to have somebody
come over and watch the kid while i'm
even there and by the way my elementary
school son
he goes to he's gone he hasn't done it
recently but he goes to people's house
while mom is home and there's just a
two-year-old and they play together so
it's kind of in-house babysitting so she
can get stuff done or he can dad can get
stuff done while they're at home
but they don't have to have they had
ears on the kid but they don't have eyes
on the kid right it's something small
like that but you need some help and
this isn't about defeat this is about
victory
okay it's not about weakness or you
didn't make it this is about oh yeah
we're definitely gonna make it and i'm
gonna start delegating because that's
how that's how much of a baller we are
okay but let's picture what we want this
thing to look like
grab that book and you'll read it
together we'll link to it in the show
notes
um it's not a faith book or anything
like that i mean it's a clinical book
and it's a direct book
but let's get into it and let's learn
what the gas pedals are and the brakes
are in our home
and the intimacy level should rise to
how you want it to be
and hopefully how he wants it to be and
y'all can meet there in the middle
awesome